[Musique]
maryse tapie est avec nous paris marie
tu as fait un truc de ouf cette semaine
oui j'étais incrusté dans un défilé état
parce que c'est le plus grand show
attendu dans la fashion week aujourd'hui
à paris parce que pour ne pas citer une
marque auquel ils veulent se mettre un
peu en concurrence
ils veulent refaire un peu le show
victoria secret's d'accord vérité donc
marque de lingerie est notre leader et
un salaire et léopold au bout des choses
simples ne passons pas à côté de jeu
donc il ya sochaux qui se perd roland
garros il ya le tout paris at on gratte
un atout gratin il va tout et je me suis
infiltré et au moment où quoi toi qui es
là bas tu es là bas donc on fait là bas
tu veux voir le privé et qui a été monté
tu t'es mis en petite tenue
elle est folle vivait déjà regardé
jaillard et à regarder
[Musique]
blablabla
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
elle
m
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous vous êtes fait pour vous incruster
il commençait patrie alors je me mets je
vois où est le vigile évidemment été
sous moi qui étais pas non plus faire
face il ya une rambarde s'est pas non
plus épaisse et pour le clou du
spectacle pas gelé en jambes et j'ai foi
il perçoit d'après une fois que vous
êtes sur le podium c'est fini geffray
j'ai fermé les yeux comme ça pendant 35
secondes
il s'est rien passé non rien de rien
battus vous êtes très belle au manioc
savez j'ai un petit petit bull alors
j'ai appris comment s'est passé après
mais ils ont rien capté
non non vous êtes reparti comme ça varie
avec lui-même qu'un nom ou fait
applaudir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]